in like maybe the late 60s we had a slip
and slide and we told her go standing up
and uh
she took off of one stand up and her
feet went up from under her and she hit
her [ __ ] hand and knocked herself out
and you know what like when nobody's
driving the car it just goes kind of
Fades off and
she landed on her head and and the water
took her but it took her like and
sputtered around like yo she just
[ __ ] ended up like like uh a car that
had run out of gas it just turned it was
so funny because she spun you know she
[ __ ] knocked out and she just spun
around like that I don't know if we were
laughing harder because she had her
[ __ ] head or then she just came to
arrest like you know
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola with me
drunk a lot of things
you know George's oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
the NFL player picture is locked in and
my go-to place for Wild Card round
action is draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL to kick off the road to Super Bowl
57 download the DraftKings Sports vocab
and use code OMG hi new customers can
bet five dollars on the NFL and get 200
in free sports bets instantly only at
draftking Sportsbook with code OMG hi
restrictions apply
see show notes for details
are you looking for an easy way to eat
well and save money this year cut back
on expensive takeout that's me and
delivery and get started with hello
fresh you'll love how fast easy and how
affordable it is to whip up a restaurant
quality meal right in your own kitchen
go to hellofresh.com OMG hi21 and use
code omghi 21 for 21 free meals plus
free shipping that's hellofresh.com
omghi 21 and use code OMG hi21 for 21
free meals plus free shipping hello
fresh America is number one meal kit
I must have had at least a half dozen
calls on that case where the four girls
or the four students were killed up in
Moscow Idaho and to do podcasts I saw
you and and uh
all [ __ ] Cavalier and [ __ ] no you had
a big word
it's like seeing your [ __ ] old lady
with some dude
her legs hurt and the last one I caught
they wanted me to go on a podcast to say
to talk about everything they were doing
wrong in the case and ask you about me
and I said no I wouldn't I wouldn't do
it because even in the the one that I
did if you saw it that was I said you
know it's that initial crime scene that
if you're not used to it really it is
hard to make up but now they had state
federal and other County officials
working it with them and I said they'll
solve it just takes time as long as it
wasn't that screwed up because I had no
idea what they found in the crime scene
is it is it they said they had them from
the beginning from day one they found
stuff in there like you know the found
DNA
um
and then you know I watched a lot of
YouTube and there's a lot of thousand I
don't say not thousands but tens of
accounts of of people who
who have followings there's one dude
circus crime he dressed up like a little
clown like with two spiders under his
eye like a white face and uh
we should try to have those some of
those dudes on and and
this dude just started right but but
he's very honest in his delivery I mean
he's wearing makeup it's like you know
but but his delivery is is such that it
gets to the information
you know if that's what you if that's
what you you that's if that's what
you're doing and then there's some where
the girls are like welcome to my channel
my well you know and just like next and
then some dude does it he's like welcome
to my Channel today you're just like
you know that's why I'm not knowing how
to present yourself I would say that not
criticism of them but but you can't talk
crime and be like hey uh everyone well
you know you got that that way the way
police come up to somebody
you want to deal with facts there's guys
I'm sure they make sense and I'm
I'm into that because there's not enough
of it and some of them are some of them
are really good but different than this
different than you would find on
Dateline per se but everybody but
everybody's a [ __ ] uh sleuth yeah and
and then you're weeding out guys that
it's like anything you know it's like it
becomes a popularity contest of course
because if you're a little bit more
factual but drab in the communication
some dude that has a white face with two
spiders under his eyes and just gives it
to you straight you kind of you kind of
take it or a lot of live chats there's a
lot of lucky guesses and once they get a
lucky guess
you know a lot of people speculate and
then they get a lucky guess a lot of
speculation and then all of a sudden see
I told you but you know what's wrong you
know what I think is is fundamentally
wrong in this Society but everything is
that the dude's guilty
and not innocent like we used to come
from a place where you were innocent
until proven guilty and now
there's just so much
that people create oh you know I I the
the first thing I told my wife she's so
good it's over I said no it's not over I
said this is just they made an arrest
that's all they got you know it's a long
way to China you know you got to get
that prosecution the evidence everything
that goes along with my hat goes off I
applaud
that small Department I don't know who
gave him advice don't talk to the Press
you don't have to give the public
anything I know and and to the father
that hired an attorney that wanted a pi
because they weren't doing anything
sorry maybe in your small town you got
power you know it you wouldn't have got
anything out here either it doesn't make
a difference that was the best thing
they did by keeping everything under
their hat that way there's no rumors
nothing gets out you're not following
the Press
and it at least up to this point and
even though they had they had DNA in the
beginning DNA is only good if you got a
DNA to match it you know so you got to
wait all that time till you get that
never been arrested yeah never had a
criminal record a PhD everybody says hey
I know this guy looks like a killer this
guy's this guy was working on his PhD
you know kind of like the Unabomber you
know he's a whiz guy
um
I don't know man like you know well you
know they make it sound like
I mean
murder's murder sure uh and you know you
go to like the BTK like guy in Wichita
yes and he became like a guy that would
go around town in a car I work for the
city and and tell you your [ __ ] grass
was too high or your hedge had to come
down and it'd be like [ __ ] is this guy
yeah [ __ ] wannabe cop yeah he wanted
to be a cop yeah and he didn't
I don't know if he he was not tall
enough but also Ed Kemper that dude that
they did mind hunter that he he killed
The Co-Ed Killer in the on the Netflix
show when they go and meet him you know
he's fascinated by crime he's [ __ ]
six nine big [ __ ] dude and he goes
yeah you know I want it to be a higher
patrolman you know and and but my mom
said I was too tall and then the guy
goes I don't think there's a height
requirement for being higher patrolman
and the look on his face was like
really like I could have done that
instead of been a killer uh-huh
and then
I don't know man his mom would give him
[ __ ]
just I don't know it's just you know
who's a cop it's hard to say because you
know
your parents give you [ __ ] but he buried
his mom's head and so he could see it
from the window I mean I I mean what is
that I think he [ __ ] his mama's mouth
there thinking
if I can take the head with you ah she
gave him head I don't know man that's I
mean can you imagine
you know you know he's a tall Reserve I
thought about Grandma in a [ __ ] bra
one time I was [ __ ] from the head
waist neck down I don't want to [ __ ]
sit on topic
there's uh Shaq O'Neal is a reserve cop
he's a reserve cop out here and he's
still a reserve cop where he's at until
somebody show hey a dude I couldn't
shoot free throw is not gonna tell me to
stop
I'll shoot okay [ __ ] hey 32 chance
you got a hitting me
uh one out of one out of three I'll take
my chances
I'm slow I'm slow and I'm big I'll get
hit you know uh but but of course you
know now
it's almost like nobody takes
responsibility for having a woman on who
said that was that guy's mom and they
everybody flocks to her you know like
see that right here and then that wasn't
who that was and they have to apologize
or that guy
did a tick tock and he sounded like the
guy and he said everybody's like that's
him
it's not him
look how much [ __ ] the the cops up
Northern California had to eat because
they were talking to the news the
kidnapped girl and guy that were
kidnapped and were gone for a week and
they came back they said they were in on
it they accused them they arrest all
this stuff and it was all wrong The
Gabby Patito thing yeah what about the
what about the mom said
to her son tell me where you are I'll
bring you a shovel
what happens there charges yeah jeez
yeah
accessory after the past yeah yeah so
she was in the house with her husband
and they were like hiding out and she
made communication with him she knew
where he was when when she told the
police uh she didn't know
and you know I think
well this is a good question
um if the police come to your house and
and interview you or any investigator
it's probably better not to lie
probably because if you lie
then you now you're in because because
you you knew
I mean it's tough man if I would if
you're there and you go I emailed my son
and I told him that I would bring a
shovel out to him why would you do that
um because he's my son and I love him
yeah
you know you know you just made yourself
an accessory yeah I I had a dad an Irish
you know his his son
uh was involved in a murder and he was
his son jumped out of a car with three
other guys to shoot up a house
he got in front of one of his homeboys
and homeboy shot him and killed him and
they got away
we ended up making the arrests we got
them all
and the D.A at the time rejected it
and the father of the decedent
came up to me he says he wanted to know
why the murder was rejected and I say
it's a DA's office we can't do anything
about it but if you want to do something
about her and I directed him because it
was a political hero again
for D.A was running problems that's what
you got to do because we tried filing
they should have been charged on
bottom line we ended up getting charged
but the father tells me he says listen
he says
if my son was doing what you said he was
doing he died like the dog that he is
and he should be dead
and then he starts crying he says don't
get me wrong I love my son but my son
has no right to take anybody else's life
and I'll do anything I can to help those
that were involved in it to get him
prosecuted and he did and we ended up
Prosecuting the guys but the dad was
what he'd given him up he'd given up
everything
I don't know man I think I think
you know that kid's I mean it just it's
just tragic everywhere I mean a guy that
wasn't popular with girls all right I
mean I would say the majority of dudes
aren't popular with girls especially if
you come off a little creepy [ __ ]
who's now you can't go to a place and
say how long you guys been working here
where do you guys live but like
[ __ ]
we're not going to tell you where we
live then you go in there a couple times
and you tell the boss hey that guy is
asking us where we live and if we're
dating anybody that's creepy man you
can't yeah
you can't you can't you can't do that
you can't you can't I mean you can't say
to someone that's my favorite waitress
the biggest come on
bring some milk hey just squirt it right
here in my face there it is huh yeah
what would they what would they do to
you should sue me after the wife picked
me up off the floor or what what yeah no
you you can't see you can't say any of
that [ __ ] know what I want I've never
been that far out you know I
I've never been that far out but I I
wouldn't be they went to the movies
until you've had to go through a popcorn
[Laughter]
I never I never did go to the show that
much you know when I was a kid I never
went into the show you know I was 16
years old 17 years old I went into the
army so I didn't and then when I came
back I was 21 when I got married
yeah what the [ __ ] yeah I don't know I
was what the hell man I don't know what
the [ __ ] you've been married for 52
years just had our anniversary 52 years
congratulations thank you that's a long
time if I'd have killed him the first
year I'd already been out of the joint
by now man you would have fun you would
have been probably 30 years hey
um
I don't know man listen I I was thinking
about that in the car I mean
uh
um
I'm not sure what people do
um
in the holidays you know I don't really
see a lot of people uh but
I'll change the subject I'll stated this
when in the early 90s uh when I was
married Ann and I bought a house in
Sherman Oaks
and the guy that we bought it from him
and his wife were retired and they were
extras in movies and shows they would
you know they'd go that was their thing
for a day there for fun
and I was on top of the roof clean out
the rain gutters and the guy I think his
name was Ted pulls up and he's kind of
halfway in the yard he looks up and he
says are you a roofer and I said no sir
are you a contractor of any kind
I said I'm not he says what do you do
for a living I said I'm a comedian
he goes well get down before you hurt
yourself and you're not able to tell
jokes and feed your family let a [ __ ]
professional do that [ __ ] and get your
ass down from there before you hurt
yourself
and whenever somebody has asked me to do
something that is not what I do
I always say
you know mine wanted me to carry some
some boxes into her house and there's
stairs and I'm like I don't I don't
think I can do that
and she's like why not I said because
I'm not a I don't carry [ __ ] boxes
around for a living there's just a few
of them I said my I'm carrying a box I
missed a step I fall I break my [ __ ]
hip then what
right good good uh uh there was a woman
that on on Blue Beetle tiny little lady
hair person has a big ass risk thing on
her wrist and I said to her how did that
happen she goes oh [ __ ] I was hanging a
curtain rod at my house I thought I had
one more step on the ladder I didn't and
I [ __ ] landed on it and broke it in
[ __ ] a million places
Jeremy remmer
got run over by his own snowmobile like
like yeah and a and a and not like when
you when you got like a John Deere
you're cutting the grass it takes you
[ __ ] two days because the little John
Deere that's my [ __ ] had he had a snow
cat like
like a big one and he has him and you
know he's out there and wherever Reno or
wherever and he clears the you know Mr
[ __ ] America he clears the snow for
his neighbors and clears the street for
his neighbors but is that what he does
he work for the Department of
Transportation in in Lake Tahoe or Reno
no
I called the Department of
Transportation for my neighbors I think
this dude God bless him I hope he's all
right there's thousands of people that
get hurt every day doing something that
is not what they do
and they can't say no are you
electrician no it's just a switch go on
that [ __ ] burn your [ __ ] house
down
right yeah it's mad
all of that stuff you're a plumber hey
it's gone the next time [ __ ] all your
[ __ ] neighbors in there [ __ ]
sleeping with [ __ ] got [ __ ] cheats
I mean people don't get it until until
they get it
like that that's 30 years that that guy
told me that no I I hired for everything
I don't do [ __ ] anything around my house
I hire somebody to do it for me hey Dad
come and help me hang the no no
[ __ ] I was hanging the lights with my
grandma this was before I was like 12
and he goes lean over here and put it on
I [ __ ] almost went over
I was looking over the house I almost
went [ __ ] over
the house almost
I was 12. and at 12 you're not playing
baseball not that I was [ __ ] uh
athletic but when I started to go over
I don't know what it is that makes your
[ __ ] onions dig into the [ __ ]
the Tower of that [ __ ] roof
that [ __ ] I was a second away from
maybe being paralyzed for life
yeah I was just like [ __ ] had a nail
under now why would I [ __ ] get off
and look I'm not I'm not [ __ ] hang
lights
he says put it nail the nail put the
nail between the two [ __ ] wires and
if I [ __ ] it and and it's already
plugged in this [ __ ] is like hey
with a [ __ ] Hammer all metal
with a [ __ ] nail grounded with a
[ __ ] metal [ __ ] like
that my grandson does all that [ __ ] for
us now he he takes over that stuff
listen this is a new year don't [ __ ]
yourself up by trying to do [ __ ] that
you don't do on the regular cow your old
lady hey if you love me
bring some other dude in there to watch
you change give you a rope no but I mean
but you people people slip in their
[ __ ] bathrooms I can't tell you how
many friends I have that have retired
and doing Simple [ __ ] hey I just climbed
up the I'm on the ladder just trimming a
bush and walk out there they're down
few of them have died some have ended up
all [ __ ] up they've a couple died yeah
and so it's just I don't the highest I
go is a curb yeah or
if you're in your 60s and you're and
you're active and you think you can do
it and you're out there with a with a
[ __ ] thing
getting oranges with a [ __ ] stick
and you touch a wire you don't even
[ __ ] see and [ __ ] bottom of the
whole [ __ ] it's like flying over
California you smell orange and you're
like you got orange juice all over the
ground
let me flying over them you know
all of that [ __ ] man that's just bad man
it's like you know
and it's in everybody's as they get
older
you just think you can do every they
want to prove to the younger people we
can still do it my swag though my
father-in-law God Rest his soul he was a
landscaper
and he was in his 70s early and he still
wanted to get up there and trim the
avocado tree polio got this down do this
do that I remember uh we had a
competitive mind was going to lay some
grass in his backyard and we were gonna
go help him you know rotate the dirt and
so I said we can do this and he's and my
father-in-law heard us talking he says
I'll go over there
and I told him I told my compiler don't
don't let him don't don't let him tell
him no you'll be sorry and he said okay
okay Julio come on down so we went down
and the first he looked at her he says
oh you guys made me a good cop but you
ain't [ __ ] at Landscaping so he redid
everything made everybody worked out
damn we got to do this he knew his
business so everybody trusted him but
when it came down he would climb up
trees still he'd do that and we'd you
know my my wife and her brother would
don't do it you know and I'd say Julio
don't do it you know no no I can still
get this and you couldn't stop the guy
fortunately he never fell down
fortunately but all you needed to fall
down is once not once that's it one time
and he it never happened and even if you
even if you you know I would tell my
grandmother because my grandmother
didn't want to walk I don't want people
to know that something's wrong with me
you're shaped like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
pretzel and [ __ ] [ __ ] Twitter who
the [ __ ] is nobody's looking at you
anyway shout chat up you know she's like
I'm like who the [ __ ] is looking at you
she'll get all mad my mom when my mom
had to go to a walker she did not want
to use a walker because that made her
look weak
and I'm not gonna use them
my grandmother was like you know
I don't want everybody to know
it's like Grandma
first of all nobody's looking at you
right and she fell
and I should tell her
it's funny because it's been so long I
mean she's been gone for not long but
it's a long day I should tell her when
after you follow the rides over like I
would tell them you know the pocket
rides over because you just can't take
it the shock
the shock of being hurt affects your but
if somebody's if somebody's 70 or 75 and
they take a they bust their hip or bust
their elbow they'll be dead within five
years my mom had a knee replaced the
first one and she had two of them she
had the first one she had done and she's
out there worded it then had to be
somebody's wedding she's irritating it
easy and give her some pisto and you
know a few shots in her and she said
come on let's go
you know and she'd get out there and
she'd dance and have a good old time you
couldn't stop the lady you know she just
it was in her dude I wasn't around my
mom a lot growing up uh fortunately but
you know in the in like maybe the late
60s we had a slip and slide and we told
her go standing up and uh
she took off and went stand up and her
feet went up from under her and she hit
her [ __ ] head and knocked herself out
and you know what like when nobody's
driving the car it just goes kind of
Fades off
she landed on her head and and the water
took her but it took her like and it
sputtered around like yo she just
[ __ ] ended up like like uh a car that
had run out of gas it just turned it was
so funny because she spun you know she
[ __ ] knocked out and she just [ __ ]
around like that I don't know if we were
laughing harder because she had her
[ __ ] head or this she just came to
arrest like you know oh foreign
Fade Out man
we laughed so [ __ ] hard and nobody
went to a resuscitated
music you know the water used to go over
that [ __ ] other [ __ ] neat Place
God damn
man that was awful man that [ __ ] my mom
my mom and dad it's some of the funniest
it's sad but it's some of the funniest
I had a swim I had us I still have I had
a swimming pool and I had a slide to go
into the pool and my mom and dad neither
one of them were swimmers and my mom
says hey
go down the slide and I'll go down my
dad said all right he says you go down
first though she says no Capital because
then you won't he says I'll go down
he talked her and we're all saying mom
don't do it mom don't I was afraid she's
gonna fall just climbing up the ladder
right because you still see it right now
yes and she went down
everybody's laughing my dad I thought he
was gonna follow he was laughing so hard
she says
and he says I ain't doing it man and he
never did he just laughed his ass off
went and ran in the house you kept what
yeah I mean
they were not Hey listen how about there
were no safety rails in the bathroom
there was no curbs with that that that
they made it for uh handicapped people
that are disabled yeah if you were if
you were in a wheelchair and you came to
this the curb you saw a [ __ ] curb
you're like
bad oh [ __ ] I can't get up there
and you know [ __ ] and and that's in
the United States in Mexico the [ __ ]
cars are this big yeah they're tall
big in Mexico [ __ ] it like this right
they got to pick you up how come why is
that because yeah because of floods
just keep the water down there's about a
[ __ ] three feet at you
they got some big curb big curbs over
there
yeah like when you run do the high jump
when you go like that you go like I'm
gonna make it on the curb and you go
like that like Dwight stones used to do
it like that and [ __ ] try to get up
over the curb [ __ ] high man yeah they
are that's all for flood control
it's holidays
yeah
all the [ __ ] gardeners there they
can't put a [ __ ] irrigation system in
Mexico
huh oh [ __ ] Waters came over here to
work over there your [ __ ] brains for
two hours [ __ ] 17 people [ __ ]
drowning a [ __ ] Diner
oh man
I had him it's awful man but I mean
I mean you see I think you just see it
like Jerry like Jeremy remmer Renner
I mean
he got he got run over by by his own
[ __ ] snow cat
I mean that [ __ ] is like I said being
put in a [ __ ] wood chipper Wow and
his dog I mean his neighbor was a
[ __ ] doctor put a turn again [ __ ] our
neighborhood
[ __ ] blood scoring all right
make my [ __ ] Cherry too that [ __ ]
dude he would have been dead oh [ __ ]
Mexican see ice everybody goes oh hey I
want waterfucker uh uh I want a Rainbow
Connection [ __ ] blood that
[ __ ] would have bled out to see
this football player
that just went down uh uh yeah yesterday
in the game yep yeah and the doc was on
the TV saying today uh he's still the
only reason he's still alive today is
because they started CPR immediately and
they they had the thing there to what
happened he just he got hit in the chest
and just went down whatever an
e-g-e-a-eg and he had a heart attack
that's that's what it was his heart
stopped he says the doctor said you have
pads yeah he had pads on them
[ __ ] nightclub and [ __ ] I'm all right
to [ __ ] shoulder pads up here the
doctor says most of the time this is it
people die from it the only reason he's
still alive today is because they had
doctors there they had people there to
jump on them I mean CPR right away try
to keep him going and he's still in
critical condition but uh that was tough
uh yeah I mean I think I think years ago
I don't think anybody's
why I mean I don't watch all the games
but
there was a I think a Detroit Lions
player that died in the 70s like but
um
I don't know man I I don't I don't think
any sport
can uh take uh athletes dying in the
course of normal play yeah and this kid
was so young he was only 24 years old I
mean what the [ __ ] yeah so it just I
I hope he doesn't die and a lot of
people praying for him but did he have
listen the thing you know it was a heart
attack [ __ ] had a heart attack
at 24. yeah
um
and I'm not a doctor but when when they
taught us no clearly his CPR and all
this [ __ ] the these teach you this what
they call a pre-cardio thumb you know
before you start
give that heart action gospel right
there it just so he got hit in the chest
and maybe he had the adverse reaction
you can stop it I I don't I don't know
yeah
I'll tell you what
Dr Lopez you go I would go there roll
them over
I'm up
I'm up hey if somebody's particularly in
your oil they go in there ain't what and
it don't work one finger you put two you
put three four
then roll them back over it but now you
guys can try your your way pronounce it
I already tried mine
yeah now you you know hurry up right one
in a million shot put one in there and
maybe he moves you know you know two
three and then
and if it you know the line's still like
that and roll them over be like okay
I've done all the best I could that's it
you glove up
just clean your hand right there on the
grass
[Laughter]
hey doctors
he's in the locker room [ __ ] too
[ __ ] far bring his ass over here you
got another vacation no no not George
again
start gently come on come on Rob what's
his name Rod whatever they [ __ ] you
know
and then you try it as many whatever his
number is 17 you try 17 don't work turn
them over
so clearly you know the guys that are
heavier have the higher numbers those
are guys that need a little more special
you stay away from me George
[ __ ] wakes up in the morning it
happened to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] up my ass
that's it you just stay awake Oh I
thought you could have beer thanks sir
hey if I go down let me die you know
what that dude was he was he was dying
them yeah yeah for all intents and
purposes it's hard to stop right there
on the field
it's hard stopped on the field when your
heart stops that means it ain't pumping
it's like you know you you burn a
bearing the engine you break an oil oil
line you burn a bearing so it just
stopped and it takes oxygen to run the
brain and run everything else he just it
wasn't there fortunately they had
medical staff right there [ __ ] man with
five minutes if nobody touches you you
know that's the point of no return most
of the time but he had people with him
within a minute starting CPR well and
then they had you know they had the CPR
they have all the equipment they have
regular team doctors there they were
able to work on them get him loaded and
get him over
and what was the hit I didn't see the
game but what was it it was a it was a
he was tackling the guy but the guy hit
him right in the chest with the helmet
you know in the tackle yeah and he stood
up you know right after that he stood up
lasted about maybe what about five
seconds standing up
and then he just passed out he just went
down
didn't look like it was anything unusual
nothing
but it was what about all those [ __ ]
Mexicans in Mexico got kicked by the
[ __ ] donkey they survived when they
come up behind them
I got kicked in a chest by a steer and
the wife says hi to your chest I said
How's my child what are you talking
about and she said you gotta Kick this I
didn't get no kick in the chest and open
up my shirt and there's two [ __ ] hoof
prince full of [ __ ] on my chest how did
that happen I was doing something stupid
that was they they had I was once
something like Rudy Myrtle fell hands
first in the fire there's there's uh for
another better I need another benefit
all right
foreign
[Laughter]
there's a lot of stuff that you don't
know about me at one point in time in my
career I was a card carrying member of
the
uh all police Rodeo Association and so
you know they had a regular rodeo and it
was from just like a a regular Rodeo
they had it was for money for buckles
you know timed and and it'd go up and
down the state and I was a card carrier
member of the [ __ ] Rodeo so what did
you do though how long could the guy
stay on your back this is what
they [ __ ] tell your [ __ ] level
eight
they couldn't come up with and to this
day they can't come up with a better way
to tie them that steers nuts in a
[ __ ] come on they go all right are
you on I bought they [ __ ] tired they
tie their nuts right yeah I don't know I
never got on a bull they have bull
riding bronc riding what did you do oh
you just went no no I was I did
something they didn't have bulldogging
you know that's where you jump off the
horse you Bulldog the street yeah that's
crazy so in order to eliminate some
injuries they had something for fun and
it was called it was called steer
dressing
and you'd get they'd get a full goddamn
steer big you know what I wish I was
[ __ ] high
instead of just a little bit because
this I know this is going to be one that
I would have liked to have been a little
bit they they put the steer in the chute
they give you it was about a 10 or 15
foot rope that was around the steer's
neck and then there's a three-man team
you had to give the steer until he got
to the chalk
and then you could run after
um and you would the three-man team
stopped the steer one guy would hit it
take it down another guy would jump on
the once the steer is down
the number two guy would jump on the
steer's belly because now the steer is
upside down the third guy I was the
third guy when you go in there you'd
have a pair of ladies panties stretch
across your chest and the holds or your
arms so I got ladies underwear right
here now as the steer is down
he's on the guy jumps on his belt he
gets the hind legs of the steer pushes
him towards me I grab the steers legs he
then grabs the panties and pulls them
down it's a timed event you did it for
money
and for buckles that was the the steer
dressing I was a steer dresser and my
family was up there watching and one of
the one of the one of the buckles say oh
they're just travels no no trans goat
competition
it was uh so you put the you put the
pantyhose on the steers yes
steers legs if if I if I were back just
imagine a steer on his back and the hind
legs up like this
and the the third guy stands there grabs
the top of those legs and the guy's
sitting on the belly pulls the panties
down on the hindquarters and it's done
for money it's them that [ __ ] it's time
to bet I I've never seen I've never
heard of that or seen it yeah
I had never did the first time I did it
I mean I didn't need an arena and
they're very protected and the steers is
like it doesn't want to you know it
doesn't you know no it doesn't want it
it's a full-grown is it a boy or a a
girl no it's a big boy with horns he's a
badass dude and and the first time I was
in there with like a big veteran balls
and everything with nylons on them
God damn the guy that talked me in was
the guy that broke me in an homicide the
guy that talked me into it yeah and
we're down there and the first time I
was down there I looked at him and I
just said you know what [ __ ] you
and he said why and I said I have no
business being down [ __ ] steer was
big man I'm down with all this [ __ ] and
now I'm scared
and it turned out and then he he
couldn't well you wearing your helmet
like oh no you had to they had they told
you how to dress you had man cowboy
boots cowboy dress cowboy hat you you
there was dress just like your golf
tournaments you know they you had to
dress like a cow and did the steer kick
like was it kicking his legs yeah the
the steers he's making noise and [ __ ]
you know he's moving his legs matter of
fact we did it uh one the last one that
I think I think at some point you're
like no Carolina come on it [ __ ]
turns you on right ah the last time I
did it like you're rubbing your whistle
against his stomach you're like come on
I burned the [ __ ] out of my hands
because the Rope I got rope burn burn oh
yeah [ __ ] uh my partner the the lead guy
he got his leg hooked up and roped the
[ __ ] steer drug him all over the
arena
and and you know a lot of people went to
pay to go see that [ __ ] Hey listen I'd
[ __ ] pay to go see that I got treated
you know by the paramedics did they do
like the sirens the [ __ ] dudes come
out it was a regular Rodeo wow and and
how come they don't do it anymore I
don't know I they still have the police
Rodeo Association because they stalked
somebody the other day uh that was doing
it and I I don't know because I just
stopped can you ask him to see uh when
they have events I can find out I think
a cruelty to animals like you can't
put nylons on Me Without Santa I wasn't
nylons they were just no garter belts
right I think maybe you know if they
want him maybe he keeps his legs close
but if he opens them up he's like hey
go save those
I don't know man yeah and he kicked and
my wife and kids were up in the stands
but who but who
I mean who had the upper hand because
that [ __ ] how that still got to
weigh 500 pounds
yeah they're big they're bad they're
nasty animals you know well not Nast
anybody die or anybody to the [ __ ]
nobody got hurt and I remember it was
kind of like a movie you know I'm
walking out my hand is a bandage and
some little kid comes hey Mommy Mommy
look at there's one of the Cowboys who's
in the rodeo and I'm sitting there how
you doing little partner he says you're
the guy that got his hands burning your
partner got run all over there
[ __ ] I want to say get the [ __ ] away
that's crazy man like guys with stars
and everything yeah and I had to go
straight from there to work
because I was working at you know what
man that's
I don't know I've never I never heard of
that it was fun it did it was fun uh did
it a few times and that was it you know
I don't need this [ __ ] somebody's gonna
get hurt you know
it's still a huge part of like of that
lifestyle I played golf in uh in New
Mexico when I was doing that golf
walking with herb
and it was a guy that
I mean
you know he just you know the rodeo
dudes like no one's gonna win the rodeo
being 5'7 like the dudes you have to be
six plus because bull riders are small
they are yeah yeah that's less weight
than low Center there was a dude there's
if you look it up uh there's a famous
bull rider who's a champion bull rider
named Gil Carrillo
not to be confused with this one I think
Gilbert Korea was from Texas him and his
brother
I believe he's still alive let's see if
we can get him in here yeah you can tell
what's I mean for Latinos I think
anytime you can play with the food
before you eat it is gonna be fun look
at look his name up as a bull rider
Aaron but there was a dude that I played
golf with and he had he we had the belt
buckle that he won you're like uh
whatever you know the rhinestone belt
buckle that he wore with when he didn't
play golf and jeans
uh one of them I mean whatever you know
they love the belt like Elvis
and uh it's like I don't give a [ __ ] if
that dude had won his kindergarten
[ __ ] bull riding competition it's
impressive to to sit on a bull and
um strap I mean you strap into where
let's imagine you know other sports like
they strap you in where you can get out
when they when they strap those dudes in
and they tighten the Rope you're really
not oh no he's got to loosen them if he
can't loosen it he's gonna give you a
[ __ ] option right yeah they don't
leave you a [ __ ] option
yeah you got to depend on those clowns
to loosen that [ __ ] up man that's a
tough fight I don't know how everybody
breaks bones in that stuff I mean [ __ ]
it must be and it's not even that long
like you know except if you stay up for
seconds eight seconds
[ __ ] and that thing is jumping and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I'm watching uh you ever thought of
running with the bulls in Spain no [ __ ]
so I'd like to watch it from a hotel
room up but you know do they still do
that yeah
there you go five five hundred twenty
five that was you in first grade that
was me and kindergarten
um wow man what the [ __ ] yeah and where
does he live
Dallas Texas I think
I think we got to reach out to him he
was a good one he was a real good one
the NFL playoff picture is locked in and
my go-to plays for Wild Card round
action is DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL to kick off the road to Super Bowl
57 new customers can bet just five
dollars and get 200 and free bets
instantly I love DraftKings because it
makes me feel like I'm in the game even
when I'm not at the game and win or lose
I always fill up on the upside man and
I've won and it's exciting that you get
to rag on your friends that don't win
but just being it's like being in the
game
it's like having a little skin in the
game download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app and use code OMG hi new customers
can bet five dollars on the NFL and get
200 in free sports bets instantly
only at draftking Sportsbook with code
OMG hi restrictions apply
see show notes for details
hey everybody's got New Year's goals and
hello fresh is here to help you achieve
them skip the grocery store and take
control of your time and budget with
delicious recipes delivered right to
your door listen man when it comes to
your door you can't help but be eating
right look for an easy way to eat well
and save money this year cut back on
expensive takeout delivery and get
started with hello fresh you'll love how
fast easy and affordable it is to whip
up restaurant quality meals right in
your own kitchen hey Aaron what are your
favorite meals you know my wife and I
love the uh Falafel powerballs uh
there's a seared steak and potatoes with
bearnaise sauce that's really good
there's a Southwest pork there's bean
burritos
what's great is that you know you come
home from work and you don't have to
really decide what you're going to make
how to make it it's all there on the
card easy peasy within 15 minutes 30
minutes it's a little it's a nice little
thing you can do together it's great I
love it go to hellofresh.com OMG hi21
and use code omghi 21 for 21 free meals
plus free shipping that's hellofresh.com
slash omghi 21 and use code OMG hi21 for
21 free meals plus free shipping hello
fresh America's number one meal kit
[Music]
good man good how are you guys good good
my apologies
um I got dropped off uh two blocks away
you didn't drive no uh Uber uh sloppy
huh uh booze how are you oh you've been
boozing oh yeah yeah man so a week
uh another podcast no this is this is it
come on man this is the one hey
um wow everybody's wearing hats though
hey welcome man welcome welcome
gentlemen happy New Year cheers happy
New Year cheers
Mr Lopez cheers how are you
um good that's good welcome we're
talking about Gil was um
Gill's a sheriff he was a former Sheriff
uh instrumental in the capture of
Richard Ramirez The Night Stalker
no uh he's yeah one of the uh stars of
um what's it called Netflix documentary
the Netflix that four-part documentary
on Netflix sure he that was me
I mean how about that I mean
[Music]
I always say this he was the one that
said it's one guy and everybody else
said it can't be one guy it's got to be
two guys one guy it's always one guy
that has the initiative the gumption to
say no we're gonna figure the one guy
that goes outside the box I went outside
the box yeah now what what why that's
always the question why did you have the
gumption to go outside the box I saw
stuff I took some classes Advanced
sexual uh Advanced questions
there were stuff there was stuff that I
could see that the non-educated cop and
old school homicide cop would not see
and so I saw this stuff and then I was
alleging something that had never been
documented in criminal history because
he was kidnapping little kids little
girls little boys
he wasn't killing them so Off the Grid
unorthodox unorthodox
but what he was doing was stuff that I
had learned from this class that I truly
believed in so when somebody sticks a
gun in front of your face right they're
not you know in front of the women it
wasn't to kill them it was just scary
you want to see him scared shitless sure
that drove his section that was sexual a
sign of sexual deviancy so how did you
know how did you pick up on because I I
I would assume would you go to the
dentist
what's that pin you have on there like a
happy tooth [ __ ] you George it is
congratulations hey you don't have any
cavities
I'm stepping in and by the way my
apologies to you gentlemen out of
respect out of respect to you I have a
cavity I gotta I gotta say out of
respect I gotta kiss the ring to Mr
Lopez no why no because why why why the
[ __ ] Comics like me look up to you
Comics like me say this gentleman well
uh like generally accomplish some real
[ __ ] ABC etc etc and so I just want to
acknowledge the moment in time where I
just say Mr Lopez are are moments in
time are so human that's limited but I
just want to say I apologize uh there's
a white piece of [ __ ] privilege bird
Chrysler that got me Hammered we're
talking about all the time yeah that's
good but I want to I want to say
apologize to you apologize to you sure
by the way for not acknowledging what it
is you're doing so very kind no
apologies to me
somebody asked him and I I don't know uh
who it was that asked him hey how did
you get these in the philippous parts
over here how do you know Philippe and I
have worked together for a long time
that was even sure he says and what
about Gil he says I don't know give the
[ __ ] hat I can't get rid of them
so I I I've been here but I mean you
know everything is True Crime now you
know everything yeah every and everybody
thinks that they're a [ __ ] sleuth and
I spend hours on [ __ ] my daughter
[ __ ] mine got me listen it's almost
like there was a comedian that said you
ever watch porn on the computer I said
no man I'm married I don't even [ __ ]
time to watch more porn it goes Redtube
Brazzers two girls like what the [ __ ] I
said last week I'm like what's that and
he's like and I look in [ __ ] 20 years
later I'm still looking up I mean it's
doing good man I wasn't looking at porn
between the tea leaves to go to to say
no there's something more because that's
what every great story is to your point
like like you always disseminate and
they go oh well
I don't think you can teach it exactly
on the very first case
short short version he pulled a gun on
Maria Hernandez and he shot her he was
within 18 inches of her now if it was
Martina uh lee or Kim would you have
cared as much wait a minute
here we go so he pulled the trigger the
lights went out in the garage because
she already hit the garage
and she went down like a sang of [ __ ]
she got hit he thinks he's just shot her
in the head she's dead what happened was
she had some keys in her hand hit the
keys didn't exit hey ended up in her
hand listen no in the [ __ ]
documentary
she shows the key it has the [ __ ]
bullet where the bullet ricocheted off
her [ __ ] hands yeah so seriously yeah
so she's alive he goes inside the condo
proper because they're in the garage she
hits a garage door opener she runs out
through the alley through the back way
she hears a second shot
back she hears a second her roommate is
inside the car sure yeah so right now if
you're watching this on on on Cinema
you'd be in your popcorn saying run
Maria run don't be stupid hey don't be
and she runs around to the front
and goes back inside she doesn't go back
inside Richard comes out the front door
he's already always Richard it's always
Richard and he is not Latino
relationship okay so he okay he then
comes out and he sees her you don't know
who's more surprised her to see him or
him to see her yeah and they start
dancing around a car and then he's got
the gun up and she finally just puts her
hands up it says Don't Shoot Me Again
you've already shot me once sure
you put the gun by his side father
walked away with that that that that's
bananas to have gotten shot in the keys
that are on your hand and say I'm that's
incredible she's no longer in fear he no
longer sees a fear in her face how does
she not fear fear well she figured [ __ ]
it I'm I'm dead I'm as good as she shot
me once that's crazy again yep he goes
down leaves you go inside the house now
you're fine
show you I wasn't just after solving
Mexican crimes Dale okazaki
Jeweler to the Stars no Japanese lady
she's in there
and when we go to the other costumes it
just felt like a Center Square yes
recorded the autopsy she's been shot
right in the forest come on right here
but she's got a contusion in the back of
her head that tells me he hit her in the
back of the head
why didn't he just kill her when he had
the shot he didn't do it he tells us
after the case after the hand I'm
sitting there talking check this out he
says
she laid there quietly and then she got
up she put her hands on top of a
countertop and she's figured he's got to
be gone he's got to be gone no these are
both women by the way not men yeah okay
no sound okay so he so she's laying
there he [ __ ] hits or she goes down
it's quiet
she's in the kitchen she go she's like
this mother he's got he's got to be gone
and when she reaches yeah it goes like
this she pulls herself up over the head
he's on the other side of the counter
waiting for her no to pull up when he
pulls up she screams that bam he shoots
right in the running lights because
because
he got off like on her fear and on the
fear in her face so now she's dead
then here's her name again Dale lokazaki
wait a minute we're not we're not
cutting it off just on Japanese women
because 40 minutes later he stops a gal
silent you
Chinese lady
[Music]
he ends up the informants on the case
the neighbors that saw this thought it
was a boyfriend girlfriend dispute
Richard was following her blocked her
she backed up into a panic stop into a
parked car engines running it's in
Reverse you can't go any place get right
there he drags her out of the car and
puts three in her on her side
why didn't he kill her while she was
right inside the car
right Dale okazaki why didn't he kill
her when he had the chance
so with a educate education that I had
but this is your job right this is where
you disseminate and so now I'm sitting
there saying there's something different
here this is signs of a sexual deviate
so it went off on it then when I found
the kids and what happened to the kids
and their descriptions that's how that's
what I did but nothing had ever been
documented in criminal history doing
that so it was a rough road to Hope
but also he was in El Paso did he killed
anywhere in El Paso uh no we couldn't
find any in El Paso uh El Paso which had
a really good solve rate for the
department they had he had a great salt
rate he had an uncle or a cousin that
went he had a cousin that went to war
yeah and came back [ __ ] up and he
killed his girlfriend in front of him
yeah
and said watch this I'm gonna I'm gonna
[ __ ] shooter and shot and shot her in
front of him he's probably 15. and he's
the one that taught Richard the small
caliber 22-25 got a choice you know
rather than a large caliber gun so
that's what Richard you guys I'm glad
I'm here uh cheers
please your Applebee's and
this is fine thank you for having me
thank you but you know they always say
oh yeah I mean you just walked in I mean
we were just giving them the description
can I say real quick we were talking
about horses right now but it's also his
partner was the guy who found the
hillside Church no really yeah my
partner with friends
plugged for Frank salero God damn it his
grandson Matt Salerno is playing for
Notre Dame great job great kid
he's just Notre Dame the college yes
he's playing Notre Dame his younger
brother's playing there I the youngest
can you figure out the play before they
call it oh [ __ ] he's he's a special
teams guy he made spectacular kid when
they played Navy he's the guy that saved
the game on a onside kick jumped on that
ball saved he's a great guy great
personality
Mom and Dad great people just I said if
you're gonna make it in the pros you go
to another game you can make it in
special teams but you got to be the you
got to throw yourself like you don't
give a [ __ ] about you guys for hearing
or anything right that's right they just
made you want to be on NBC you gotta
[ __ ] come through
he's taken one more year there he's
working on his PhD there now he still
has they they let one year one more year
of Eligibility he wants to play again as
a special teams guy you think he's
staying till they get some [ __ ] or he's
really trying to get it back
[Laughter]
but two for two for two now I'm gonna
tell another person I'm gonna tell you
they had a t-shirt made it so I saw it
on the internet today and he's a special
teams Guy Do they still call it the
internet but on the back of the t-shirt
on the front of the you know because
they just won the Gator Bowl or some
kind of bowl this weekend and so it says
congratulated Champions Notre Dame on
the back it has Irish Notre Dame and
that only allows us
they named they named as many letters as
it said and by using team members and
Matt Salerno's name is on the back of
that shirt for special teams guy
well can can I say something so I think
special teams like
what you saw in Buffalo Cincinnati the
other night right like yeah there there
comes a moment where you all we we all
want to disseminate we well we don't
want to was that the Special Teams guy
that that had the harder time no no no
no no no he's not but he's he's out of
Pittsburgh where I'm from right he was
drafted out of the pit and gone to
Buffalo I think 226 uh uh draft pick but
I hope I haven't seen a sunny day in
[ __ ] 10 years [ __ ] Pittsburgh if
they go to Buffalo God damn can we start
over with Cuba yeah of course [ __ ] but I
think we we all at the end of the day
like you look for these glimmers of Hope
but right but then I I think when you
hear these disseminations you just just
think hey let's just all root for each
other right so I I think like when you
hear these stories like right the
gentleman at a buffalo you like you just
say hey man cheers I I hope you come
through I hope people pull through no
matter what it is no matter what we're
doing with so sure what about um how do
you feel about we're talking about
Jeremy Rembert trying to
do something that professionals do like
you know
um and getting hurt unfortunately but
also like with a snowplow yeah you've
got run over by his own snow plow by the
way that's the story nobody's talking
about this guy did his own slowpot yeah
any and and they're not little they're
not like John Deere hey let me do it
Grandpa again and this [ __ ]
like tell me why yeah he's clearing out
the streets but again
well I was telling gills that a guy 30
years ago I was on the roof he told me
the house and he's like are you a Rover
are you a [ __ ] a handyman get down
before you hurt yourself and you're not
able to do what you do for a living and
man you're out there in the [ __ ] snow
he's trying to beat the weather and yeah
and he [ __ ] runs it [ __ ] runs over
him man an Avenger it's all a [ __ ]
Avenger he's not saying ABC take care of
this I got it yeah I got it yeah I mean
he ran over himself I
flew for The Avengers Infinity what the
[ __ ] man
he ran over himself
quote unquote
it's a single car a single snow plow
accident
and his neighbor was a [ __ ] doctor
you know God bless him man but if your
neighbor's not a doctor you're [ __ ] out
there
it's like it's probably just ran oh man
too late he wants to I mean uh he wanted
to beat the weather
but you're in that category whether one
George don't pretend you're not in that
category too because you're sneaky
you're you're a [ __ ] selfie Jeremy
Renner I know man [ __ ] badass man
badass Avenger but I'll take a here's
the thing if you put him on a scale
if you put them on a scale
you go Ray Romano don't put me on a
scale you go George Lopez Ray Romano you
put him on a scale with an Avenger I I
would in this day and age of
entertainment 10 years ago I go Avenger
this day and age I go well [ __ ] maybe
maybe Lopez maybe wait yeah because I
think you're as successful
as any of those guys because we all yeah
in the summer but I play it down you
play it way down by the way way down I
think you do I think you wait I think
you do
I played them I finally I've never said
that I've never said that before but I
do that I play it down you're a piece of
[ __ ] are you okay you [ __ ] take
advantage of the system
and by the way I'm gonna say this I
applaud you okay so guys marlago
2023 are you there
he kissed a [ __ ] Trace [ __ ] some
dude's wife on the head that
[ __ ] but I will say this I I
swear to God people you know you have
these conversations and entertainment
you go I think this person might be more
successful I think George Lopez is more
successful than Jeremy Renner no I
wouldn't I would because I a movie is a
is a quick hit it's a quick hit of six
figures seven I mean seven even
I don't know
I'm not rich I'm not an actor I get
recognized more and asked to take
pictures from people from The George
Lopez podcast and I do from the uh I
don't know Steve documentary I don't
know dude case in point let's go [ __ ]
yourself let's let's see your tax
returns um let's talk
you know how did you turn the amazing
Jonathan into a [ __ ] Academy Award
nominated documentary well I'll tell you
this right now okay real quick between
three of us yes sir you know I've been
out there a long time yes I've seen
Jonathan around and when I saw the
documentary absolutely the best and all
of the awards and all the things
congratulations man well thank you but
it's also like a testament I think when
you're a comedian right you're coming up
you you look to the people that you
appreciate sure and then the people you
Aspire towards and respect you go if I
could ever kiss the ring and then this
moment in time comes comes about you say
I just want to acknowledge that and you
go why doesn't anybody do a doc about
that individual then you say
well this day and age by the way this is
like four years ago I'll do that and
then this day and age like presently you
could anybody could do that anybody
could do a doc about you you're doing a
few about anybody the the the the
industry has is so fractured Niche these
days it does not matter anymore it
doesn't matter like
I I I really that's why like what was
the process of
how did you want to do a documentary
because you're you're still doing
standard you're still writing you're
doing your own thing yes sir and it
takes a lot of time to focus on someone
else yes and then go through the ride in
the preparation then shooting it and
then the
you know they start to get some
attention it's a three it's almost a
three and four year [ __ ] ride right
well you need a story though you you
could go oh this this gentleman is gonna
pass he's he's gonna expire but you also
still want to acknowledge well what is
the story do I have a story to tell if
you don't have a story don't make a
doctor and
um there's also Credence right you like
you want to still like acknowledge like
there's people like you Ray Romano uh
Seinfeld there's people
um that still have this acknowledgments
uh like of gravity where where you still
go you could build off of that so how do
you build off of that and so with
Jonathan the the build off was
here's a gentleman that came to Vegas
that is a headliner that um
that is dying and he's gonna die and
then he died he he he knows it's going
to expire so he withdraws from the scene
but then he comes back for three more
shows it's like oh well there's the
impetus there's the uh draw for a a
documentary right so you you do that and
um if not for the fine folks at all
things comedy to uh say uh I think we do
this uh that's when you do it amazing
[ __ ] amazing but again
it's not without
I I I don't want to sound too saccharine
George I swear to God I don't want to
sound I see that I don't want to sound
too like um acknowledging of like people
that like I think this day and age right
now presently
there are people that are going forward
in the world of entertainment and comedy
especially that just
they're not taking acknowledge of the
people I I swear to God the forefathers
of people that came before them well I'm
gonna agree to that when I when I'm
coming up there's still an
acknowledgment of of Carson and Bob Hope
a Dangerfield of uh like all these
people in late night talk show or
whatever like in in terms of the world
of Comedy where you acknowledge you go
thank you thank you thank you and by the
way thank you George thank you right all
these people that are the conduits of
like pulling the bear of weight to move
into this next faction and so I think
you're seeing that with Andrew Schultz
you're seeing that with um
with Rogan obviously he's the biggest
tentpole and then all the people under
the umbrella of Rogan but there's people
that just before the semblers Rogan
because Rogan's like this precipice of
um
of
you know podcasting and Bill Burr and
how magical etc etc but but you have
this acknowledgment of like a broad
schematic of like true Talent you but
this guy did Joe Rogan lose some of his
nuance
in that in this podcast deal because he
had to take a hard stand on on politics
and and stuff and also
um we'll look at Elon look at Eli right
what happened with him he he was he was
uh like a conduit of like uh he was a
Beacon of Hope [ __ ] everybody loved
him oh my God he's amazing the mini
comes out I I'm so stuck on precipice
something about your patio yeah so her
quinceanera is next week
[Laughter]
Elon is just coming out like I'm
slightly conservative I might and then
everybody comes after him it's like but
just listen to the Vantage Point listen
to his what he's saying communicating
and it's like it's not the schematics of
I think the schematics of mainstream
media the schematics of um entertainment
the schematics of how we divulge and
appreciate our
film entertainment TV shows it's so
different than when we all came up
before it was three networks maybe four
or five and now it's completely it's so
fractured the LA is different than where
we came from absolutely I mean
um speaking of this this this
Johnny Carson is Johnny Carson's uh
Rolex shut the [ __ ] up are you kidding
me
yeah I bought it um it came up for sale
um a woman that is my wardrobe person
knows that I'm a huge comedy fan and uh
he wore at the first show in 1979 Bo
Derek was a guest on the show
are you serious it came up and she's
this guy Hans said said to her her
ask George
kind of crazy if he's interested in
Johnny Carson's Rolex
and
um she said you know he gave Alex who is
married to gave it uh to him as a gift
he had an award for from 79 to 92. no
the first time he wore it was
are you kidding me George when he was
oh No George he was he was introducing
you'll see it
it's right there it's right there I was
left that's what's up and he just wore
it on channel four uh
George come on are you kidding me
that's it
so
it came to me and she said
um do you want us do you want to see it
I said I said yeah I want to see it
if you hold it you'll feel power if I
feel it so I'm going to tell you
something you'll feel power from it my
last hour special uh is called the last
late night and it was an homage to the
last Nate talk show I started Carson
Dean Martin uh Dangerfield Bob Hope all
the greats back in the day and I studied
their uh Credence like uh technicalities
so much that it this means a lot to me
so when you're saying this like I'm like
I'm really [ __ ] bowled over man so
she she didn't have it she she said to
me
um
do you want to see it because it you
know it has to it can't just travel like
he'll bring it and I'll meet him at the
gate and he'll give it to me and yeah
you'll see it and I said of course I
mean I did The Tonight Show in 90
91 six months before he left he was
wearing this when I shook his hand come
on Maddie can I see it honestly I would
I would take this on like knowing when I
I was in my dressing room you know at
NBC Universal across where the tour
where the trams go sure is the Johnny
Carson building yeah so I see it from my
couch when I'm working on my scripts I
see Johnny Carson build means everything
to me that's growing up
and when she takes it out and I hold it
like this I feel this [ __ ] thing go
through me man like like
threw me almost like a like a pillar of
just straight light go through me and
out
and she's like what do you think and I'm
like
I gotta take I gotta buy it I have to
buy it I want it
you know I want it I don't and she's
like Dick Wolf wants to look at it [ __ ]
Dick Wolf like I grew up watching
[ __ ] Johnny Carson dick welcome to
the crime scene and he'll figure it out
it's me it leads to me [ __ ] dick like if
Jordan doesn't want it Dick Wolf once
you look at it I said I mean
the bezel is different it's in good
hands listen it's in good hands boys
it's in the hand of a comedian
it's in good hands
um I just started to wear it by the way
listen Mommy I'm sorry I take this I'm
gonna
cry Jimmy Fallon I gave it I showed it
on The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
yeah you feel it you feel the weight
[ __ ] amen feel the weight you feel
the weight he was Eddie Murphy and him
talked about watches and then he's like
yeah I'm a watch guy Johnny said yeah me
too and [ __ ] wearing that watch
Johnny
dude I I I've seen what you did uh what
he did Beverly Hills Cop he went on
there and he had like a jacket the thing
and he's like you're talking about
watches and he's like yeah I bought it
you know I gotta watch I watched the
television recently Jimmy Fallon then I
thought he was coming on they were
talking about Lopez versus Lopez
and
I told my wife before he said anything I
said he's got the watch on he's got it
and he's gonna talk about it because he
knows what it means I knew the story and
I know how much it meant to him and I
said I had to bring it home to New York
when I did this special right so the
last late night it was an homage to the
late night last to the late night talk
show I called it the last late night for
a reason because
people don't realize like um
like I did the history I I did the work
I'm not just doing it just to do it no
that's no it's like there's a
precipitous and I want to bring you up
because I don't think people really know
what you meant to the landscape a late
night because I I really did the work on
this
um the late night talk show
um much like the variety show right the
80s well we go back to 60s 70s right
eyes off right yeah dies off slowly and
then the late night talk show is ours
but it's slowly dying off with streaming
and
and it's a launching pad for comedians
so that's why I called it the last late
night but then
I I think the thing that gets everybody
talks about when you talk about late
night talk shows which nobody really
truly acknowledges other than like
someone like Bill Carter or a few people
that like comedians that really
acknowledge the history and and Kevin
still alive and I went through it and
you have a one of the more significant
parts of it because
I would love to hear your perspective on
I'm going to be as I'm going to be very
judgmental and Broad and withdraw myself
but I will say that everything in in my
in my research
just from a perspective of like a fan
but also a comedian yes and this is why
I really appreciate this moment to get
to sit down and talk with you and I you
can edit out anything or not okay I'll
tell you I understand I know where
you're going and I have great uh great
stories but everything I have I I've
read and accumulated and researched and
appreciated I I I do think that Conan is
a
I think he is as much a conduit and
appreciative of what
the Legacy meant to him right
I think your
if you look at the if you look at the
history of late night talk shows the
biggest casualty of it all is you and
nobody's ever acknowledged the fact that
you are the biggest casualty because
people can say Conan uh Leno uh Conan
you're at the tail end of it because you
you were right there and you had a thing
you had something that was happening and
then everybody [ __ ] dis acknowledge
it and then Conan came in and he did it
he did everything everything that was
communicated to the general public about
late night talk shows that was bestowed
upon Conan
was actually in reality bestowed upon
you silently nobody ever really
acknowledged it and I really believe
that why is not anybody ever
acknowledged the like the moment in time
for you so I I just I I feel very as a
fan of late night I'm sorry
George I feel like like I I get angry
about it I'm like why is not anybody
acknowledged what you've been through um
first of all
The Tonight Show was and I love you and
I respect you as a comedian but I just
want to say this before you before you I
I really I really mean that yeah so I'm
sorry good
um
The Tonight Show was a job that you had
for forever it was like being a maid guy
yes Dick Cavett Jack Parr Johnny Carson
Johnny Carson wasn't gonna retire until
Jay Leno's manager planted that story
right that this was going to be his last
year yes and then when NBC didn't come
forward and say
wait a minute that's [ __ ] yeah
Johnny Carson said wait a minute you
[ __ ]
haven't come forward and said it's not
my last year that's Hollywood by the way
that's they're just waiting so Johnny
Carson goes to the upfronts in New York
they're still up there and NBC up front
he's the Jewel of the upfronts he's The
Tonight Show he walks out there and he
says I just want everybody to know that
May 29th of 92 is going to be my last
show and he [ __ ] walks off he's
wearing this watch
and [ __ ] walks off and goes to
Letterman that night and they make fun
of NBC and they make fun of Jay Leno and
Jay Leno became
the guy who had a manager Helen Kushner
got arrested whatever the [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] she is that pulled the [ __ ] rug
out from Johnny when NBC was waiting to
see what that [ __ ] John is like you
[ __ ] don't aren't going to come
out and say this [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys
didn't
there were better choices Letterman Gary
Shandling
but Jay Leno hid in the closet I mean
crazy [ __ ] yeah crazy [ __ ] but also not
connective to anything he's just a he's
just no he wants the next thing had no
respect my question to you is did Conan
he did not he was not as um not as bad
but Jay Leno went to 10 o'clock he put
things in motion that shouldn't have
been there he should have just went away
but the story the the the the story that
was perpetuated in the public right was
like oh this is what happened Conan
Conan's victim right and then uh Leno is
the the savior because of the metrics
right but if you go by the metrics the
metrics the metrics said you were the
[ __ ] savior the magic word that you
were the [ __ ] guy because you created
a party atmosphere that's right you you
were the new Arsenio you were the and I
swear to God I like I just I I
okay so I'm sorry you so I I would even
I mean we didn't do a desk I didn't even
have cards
I didn't have a car I had I had a
monitor Maybe
at the end of the stage and it would
roll it would roll and say
you know ask Steve about growing up in
Jersey
and then I would it would I would look
at it and if I didn't get there the guy
that was working in the in the trailer
knew me and he'd roll up and say
Pittsburgh ask him about Pittsburgh
right and he [ __ ] we were I didn't
have an earpiece I [ __ ] did it all
from that
and we wanted to do the party and I even
said to Jim territory got arrested Soul
he was you said on streets
I shut down in Hollywood that [ __ ]
thing and I said to Jim I said hey man I
wish I had to take like a class or some
[ __ ] like you know interviewing class he
goes hey you're curious and that's what
your strength is and you're curious
you're a fan you're curious you you want
to know and you know what
uh they [ __ ] it up when they got rid
of me and Conan never did the numbers
that I was doing even when I left
he don't he this they put a [ __ ] 100
million dollars in that [ __ ] thing
this is what infuriates me as somebody
that um is a fan of the late night talk
show uh Community like as a as a comic
is that you cone did it he did it all
at the beginning he never did it at the
end and that's what made me angry made
me Furious because I I'm like a student
of it like I really appreciate I did the
work I'm like what the [ __ ] how do you
not acknowledge this like so if you're
going to acknowledge the beginning you
gotta acknowledge the the end too you
know
um
because your ratings were there
absolutely and the first show we we did
a we did a test show outside by ER
about a year and a half before and I had
to do the my own guess I got Kaley Cuoco
was a friend of mine from by the way
where's the camera where's the camera
this is not I did not come on here like
talking to George before I'm sorry I
really like I genuinely like love and
respect you so to be here
I really take this as a um
Chris
I had I'll shake my hips I had dank I
had Dane Cook I had Dane Cook uh come
out I had Kaley Cuoco had Eva Longoria
and Sam Jackson sure that was my pilot
then we got picked up and then we went
for the outside look inside and I had
Eva
Kobe Bryant
Alan popped in and Carlos Santana wow
and those were all my friends and we
were off and running man
and we were off and then every day I
went to work and they said not enough
women are watching none of men are
watching not enough Latinos are watching
not enough black women are watching no
white people are watching too many black
people are watching Jesus Christ too
many Latinos are watching and every day
was something that just was like
like you're [ __ ] somebody has your
hand in your pants every [ __ ] day you
can't go in there and just go hey boss
great show last good show yeah great
show
um
from from the beginning I mean
incredible Moment Justin Bieber's first
late night I took him to the [ __ ]
door and measured his head with a
[ __ ] marker and the next time he came
back I measured it again it [ __ ]
grown that I mean just [ __ ] that was
like and and the stage was big yeah it
was open it was a party I would enter
and I would introduce people from the
audience from the back like 50 Cent came
on with Mark Harmon
and Markham was a quarterback at UCLA at
50s across the audience in the [ __ ]
window and Mark Harmon takes his
football and [ __ ] throws it and 50
Cent catches it in the [ __ ] window
and I shoot an arrow at Eric Estrada
ah man I mean it was like it was on it
was I'm still watching them
I think what Arsenio did was Arsenio
prior to Carson and I I will say this
Carson's the best Carson is the best the
day-to-day [ __ ] funny
real you know it was he was with uh
Richard Pryor talk about getting you're
getting married again he's like I don't
do it and they both repel and they just
yeah because they're [ __ ] he got
married four times yeah and he's like
are you married right I go snow are you
because I don't know
and but there was always like conduits
of like uh and then Arsenio took over
and then you took over and you had a
brief moment in time and I I don't think
the industry ever gave you from somebody
like an outsider's perspective this is
just me I'm just a comic I'm just
somebody and I'm I'm rooting in the
Rings to go oh finally [ __ ] finally
the it's whites then it's Latinos then
it's blacks then it's Asians and so you
go by the percentages of like what we
all Merit or whatever it's about time
Latinos took over and had a voice in
this perspective for you now and they
Steve that they
that [ __ ] audience there was 750
people
in in our [ __ ] audience 750.
because I was used to doing you know
[ __ ] theaters that um when [ __ ]
Conan came out he's like
like he came to introduce his show and
he goes wait a minute is this all the
people I said oh it's going to be full
every night every night you go I could
never do this I ran out if you remember
the beginning of the show I ran out yeah
I usually I say introduce the guy and
the guy you're an Entertainer I [ __ ]
ran out there because Mike Tyson said
when he started fighting he ran because
he wanted the guy he was fighting to
know that he was in a fight as fast as
[ __ ] possible he's in his corner I
got that so I was like I'm gonna run out
there and I slid through the whole thing
and that was my way of saying I want
them to know that we're going to get
down as fast as I can get to that
[ __ ] George's Point like to George's
Point George
came up from a cloth of Assassins
there's people like yourself that come
out just like I'm not I'm not going to
go in the pocket look I love Stephen
Wright Steven Wright is a [ __ ]
fantastic one of the best Comics sure
after 15 minutes yeah get me the [ __ ]
out of here that's true I want to watch
you on New Year's Eve I want to watch
you in New York the New Year's Eve in
Vegas or Vegas like la like I want to
watch there's certain people that are
Comics that are entertainers that that
understand Showmanship even Jimmy even
even Jimmy when he came in into even
Jimmy when he came into my dressing room
when I did this nice show and he goes
you've been golfing I said oh I'm over
there doing that's my jam and I'm like
oh yeah golf right there you know across
the thing he goes oh when I come back we
should do a put a bridge across and cut
the chain the Lakeside to go and just
easy because he's almost coming exactly
take over those are going to take over
but I think there's people that that can
do that and then there's other people
that can't do that there's people that
can't they can't get out of their own
way so for me so I go do The Tonight
Show in New York because
before you finish I just want to say
this to you okay
from a comedian from a Comics
perspective like I genuinely
I'm sitting in the pocket I'm just a
comic I'm just a stand-up comedian I
don't mean [ __ ] to anybody okay but I
know that there's certain people out
there in the world in the ethos that are
just doing the [ __ ] work that are
doing what it takes and there's reasons
you're begotten all these things along
the way with major networks that say
we're going to invest in this individual
and there's a reason for it so when I
see someone like George when I see
somebody like XYZ and you go I get it
now I I totally get it there's people
that you can Bank on like I generally
you feel like I'm connected I'm still
connected connected but connected not
not connected to the to to people yeah
to the [ __ ] people because that's
what matters the most you Larry the
Cable Guy there's people that just
connect and they go oh they [ __ ] get
it that's that's that's the [ __ ]
sauce that's the sauce that people the
industry does not get it's like go ahead
bid on Pearl Jam but I'm going to tell
you some Larry the Cable Guy that's the
[ __ ] sauce that's the people you have
these things where people go oh now
everybody gets it that's what we all
want that's the conduit of it all so my
apologies for like striking a little
more uh aggressive narrative but I'm
just saying I really appreciate this
moment in time to sit down with you but
also like there's a reason for it George
I I really appreciate it but also also
[ __ ] you but I don't know seriously
ethos and purpose
it's education
no but listen listen man I mean
it's like somebody says oh you still do
stand up you know like and
I just go like hey man
if you could fly
wouldn't you want to fly for as long as
you could fly sure like like like the
guy's 24 years old had a heart attack if
they tell him hey man listen man if you
go on that field again you're risk dying
nobody's gonna go sure and he's gonna
and 24 he's done and Guy Ali as great as
Ali was as great as anybody's been
that time is the [ __ ] master and says
you know Oscar De La Hoya went before
Pacquiao I went up to the bucket Lake
Arrowhead and he said to me in the car
around he said
George
by the way this isn't a Ford Focus yeah
he goes when I went up he goes and no
nylons hey
he said
up here and I'd run forever
and now it's a job like I get up and I
don't want to run and that's when you
know
that you're [ __ ] it's not that you
don't love it it's you just had too many
mornings man so George can I ask you
this you you you've been a headliner
because I think there's comedians say oh
my uh I can sell tickets don't matter
you're not a headliner a headliner means
you're you're resident right you've been
a headliner for years what um
what's been the difference
between perspective of a headliner from
when you start
to where you are now what does a
headliner mean to you because headliner
means nothing to anybody right now
people don't give a [ __ ] about that
right but in the comedy community like
listen it still means something so what
does it mean when you go to the hospital
and the receptionist meets you
and you say uh uh why are you here oh I
have a little bit of indigestion okay
you move to another room and then uh
[ __ ] uh uh a nurse might go in there
and and what are you here today for uh I
have a little bit of indigestion I'm not
feeling really good then someone else
comes in and then the doctor comes in
and says what's the problem right I have
this I want to check you out I'm going
to get you fixed up he has all the
answers the [ __ ] headliner is the
[ __ ] that has to go out there
right in that time
make you laugh and make you forget all
your other [ __ ] and make you realize
that you came for the right reason you
came to see a guy sure you've been doing
it a long time the other guy's ah 15 20
minutes and you come and they were like
they were never there sure okay Robin
Williams
got a friend of mine loved them I was
telling these guys I went to apla at the
at the uh at the amphitheater and this
was in the night early night I wasn't a
headline or anything
Jennifer Holliday went out there let me
just say this you always have a
Headliners
come on you know it you know Jennifer
Holliday goes out there yeah sings one
song dream girl sings another one that
[ __ ] nobody stop clapping and she
looks over she's like did you do another
one
and then I look at I was married I
looked at Anne I go I wonder who's next
[ __ ] Robin Williams comes out but but
that's you but that's right you've never
said and Jung Ken Jung and I talked
about our first moved here he goes
George Lopez that's right he [ __ ]
rocked that out I took him out and I go
oh he's so [ __ ] and that's the point
of a headliner so I don't mean it I
don't mean to cut you off but he went
out there and he never said how about
that he [ __ ] went in there and he dug
in and in two minutes it was like she
was never there
he didn't acknowledge her right he
didn't acknowledge that the people
wouldn't stop clapping he went out there
they saw him it was a shift and it's
almost like when you see birds go one
way and then they [ __ ] come they go
yeah because when when she left they
were all going this way and then he
walked out he did the whole thing you
know you did it the whole grabbed his
nuts and all of a sudden you start
seeing it come back and you're like
and then two minutes in I'm sitting in
the [ __ ] Amphitheater it's not there
anymore and I said to and I go it was
like she was never here
he didn't [ __ ] acknowledge and he
went into his own [ __ ] right he was like
I don't give a [ __ ] what you just saw
Here I Am
that's like there's a new class and then
there's a new class a new class a new
class it's always and also but also you
know like
before the [ __ ] internet yeah late
night was your [ __ ] internet that was
it that was uh Dom kirschner's Rock
concert Midnight Special [ __ ] Fridays
sure The Tonight Show all of that [ __ ]
was you know
I would tell my friend hey man wake me
up at [ __ ] 11 30 so we could watch
The Tonight Show I watched [ __ ] The
Tonight Show in all of my friends houses
if I ever stayed over like yeah I just
did
and then here I am man well lope here's
here's what you you might respect is
that when I did the special right
there's Ebbs and flows to the to the
monologue jokes right because I
researched I I watched Johnny I watched
um Bob Hope Dangerfield Dean Martin all
these people I I talked to Dean Martin's
neighbor that's how sick I got about
this [ __ ] [ __ ] amazing there's Ebbs
and flows to the to the monologue jokes
in the hour special so when I when I
when you hit
Peaks valleys all of it it was like my
favorite aspect of the Carson monologue
was when a joke bombed right I loved it
I loved it and so I was like let's do
that let's go here and here you think
they put those things in there on
purpose I don't think they did it but I
did it so I don't think they did it
because I talked to a few of them
because I really I reached out to them a
few of them I called them that's how
crazy I was about this [ __ ]
and are you ready to watch that gill I'm
ready to watch anything that thing is
[ __ ] incredible ma'am it it really I
I it's a [ __ ] it's scientific it is
scientific but it's scientific to the
point for you and me it's scientific to
you and me not to the viewer the viewer
is going to go oh okay but the the
comedian goes how do I bet this I I I I
just seriously Swiss Army right amazing
I'm a student of comedians I I love them
there's like here because he wants to be
a comedian there's nothing better than
making he wants to play
I I came here one day the first comedian
I ever paid to go see was Don Carrera
Dom Herrera or Don Carrera Dom Carrera
Dom Ira one of the greatest Comics out
of Philadelphia by the way I'll tell you
this right now
I saw I saw his special
the young comedian special out of
dangerfields I watched this recently it
holds up to this day to this day it's
still [ __ ] good it was filmed 27
years ago
is one of the greatest Comics he was you
might be right he was one of the
funniest men I'd ever as first guy I
ever paid to go see yeah and and I just
love
comedy and and and his stuff uh I go not
so right what about Saget man
oh I've been saying it in in seventies
by the way how about you no no yeah by
the way George every time I talk about
Jordan
George you you I I think you said
you you sit in that pocket to beat too
deep but I'm telling you there's been a
multitude of people over the years of my
years I I started in New York I went to
2004 then I went out where'd you go to
New York uh Tommy seller was my home
base for like six years but you never go
to New York you got to go to The Comedy
Cellar manager all right this [ __ ] but
I'll tell you over the course of my
years going out all these years
there's been a multitude of like maybe
10 names I hear over and over again and
you're one of those names in the ten and
I'm telling you you you you should take
acknowledgment
and appreciation of the fact that you I
know
but you need something you did something
significant within the sitcom realm
which was always the um
the invitation to people that did not
know comedy it was Tim Allen it was
Seinfeld it was Roseanne it was you via
Sandra Bullock taking because I I again
I'm done but but also it's just not that
introduction it was you it was you that
did that
because people then got to know you I I
I would never negate the fact that you
did something very important and
significant and by the way for me as a
kid that was sitting there watching
sitcoms back in the day going who the
[ __ ] is this person and I go oh he's
George Lopez who's the [ __ ] George
lope and then I you know you you look it
up and it's like oh this is a person
that represents 14 of the [ __ ]
American population and he's he's
talking for engine like all these other
comedians that I respect that I love
like I um I could sit here and get
emotional about it but I I think people
don't realize the work that goes in this
stuff it's like I really do appreciate
what you've done
sure what you've done I think I think
that there's a uh you know I think that
there's
you know crime comedy acting movies
there's no bottom to it man it's a very
paper-thin box just really leave no
place to land I started with him on
episode 11. we just dropped last week
this week number 92 and I've been on all
but three of them with them and I'm
still trying to figure out where are you
in those [ __ ] three
[ __ ] cowboy rodeo
this [ __ ] was the Rodeo Man
has been as much fun has been as
educating for me and it's just it's
really been uh it's really been great
you know I do people study it like a
like a genre like they would study porn
films oh I think even worse so I think
even more so yeah don't you think
you're you're you know what matters when
you're not on the on the golf course
okay when you're not on the golf course
do you not do not acknowledge people are
dissecting everything these days I will
tell you I will tell you I will tell you
this you know my friend Ernie my first
friend God Rest his soul yes yeah uh had
a had had on TV in 1979 out here it
turned into HBO it's called on TV yeah
you had a box on your TV of course
everybody at [ __ ] 10 o'clock you
would turn it on I couldn't afford it I
remember it [ __ ] auntie and and he
vhsed Richard Pryor live in Long Beach
yes and he and he said to me you have to
come over and watch this and I went over
there and we sat
in his bedroom on Rinaldi and Savannah
mission
and he made me a cassette and I came
home
and I watched that thing five thousand
times my grandma would be like you're
watching that I mean just forever yeah
um
I mean
I knew him in the 90s sure
I knew him in the 2000s I knew him when
he was sick
and I'm responsible for his statue being
up in Peoria like it was half done and I
said along with prior by the way I said
we got to finish this [ __ ] statue and
we raise the money me Cedric DL Charlie
Murphy got wrestling Mike Epps and uh
Cedric [ __ ] and we did it and that
statue stands and and I I don't think
you realize is that there's a lot of
young comedians out there and I've heard
this a multiple amount of times
and again I'm withdrawing emotion from
this okay is that
um there are individuals that look at
you look at you as a conduit
to exhibit their future in comedy
exhibit their Moment In Time to Say Hey
I I can still do this too and I think
that's that's your moment in time to
give to the Future so you're doing it by
the way yes yes
[Laughter]
but also but also Steve like
with the first show and that was all
brand new I never walked around like I
didn't belong in that air you should I
might not have of uh you know I might
not have walked but when somebody saw me
I didn't I didn't walk like I didn't
belong once
should never ever [ __ ] I never
[ __ ] was like ashamed of who I was
like all those Laker games I still do
watch hey man by the way I I think when
I look at like uh someone is um
I want to be very careful when I say
this I want to when I look at somebody
as the pantheon of late night talk show
right I go Steve Allen I go Johnny
Carson
and I would honestly say
I would go George Lopez because not made
it was a great two years
it was a great two years but you know
what I mean I think that people don't
acknowledge there was a legacy that was
passed upon in the world of late night
talk shows so when I when I call this
the the last late night talk show I was
not negating
um late night talk show I I did the I
did the work I I I really researched it
I really
like gave a [ __ ] about it and your
whether you're acknowledging it or not
which I know you are but I'm telling to
people that don't know
you generally are a huge significant
part of this moment in time that people
even
right now are not acknowledging but I am
I'm telling you you know George Lopez
was an an immense conduit from if you go
from Steve Allen
to Johnny Carson to Jay Leno
and I go like this and then I go to
Arsenio Hall because he was fractured by
the fact that our city was coming in
within and he got [ __ ] with Letterman
moving to CBS
then it's you then it's you you're the
biggest name to come into play it's not
Conan it's not Letterman it's not
anybody else I'm telling you I swear to
God
if you're Bill Carter if you're anybody
they all know George Lopez is the name
that comes in the conversation and that
gets stifled by everything everything
was victimized by yeah take all the
victimization put it right here with
George Lopez it's not victimization by
the way it is reality it is reality
going upon George Lopez and it [ __ ]
like this is five six years ago this is
seven years ago it infuriates me as a
person that appreciates light and comedy
so sorry so much money in there and cut
them down to like half an hour
cut them down to [ __ ] only on the web
yeah I haven't I I have an honest
question I I don't know the business
it almost sounds like was it
no no no I I think
it's not premeditated no it's just the
way I just think the way if you make
listen man how many times you go to New
York or you go to a store and say we're
closing the [ __ ] stays open
everybody goes in there to see it they
they were never they were never
vilifying George Lopez but I will say
the biggest victim of the late night
Wars before the late night Wars uh
concluded before the late night Wars
ended I think before everything hit a
precipice before everything wrapped up I
promise you this I swear to God George I
pressed a pissed in my pants right now
that's the third time
George Lopez is the biggest
victim of it all I I really believe that
I went uh out of the country on a three
four day vacation and Jeff Ross was in
the same community and my manager said
by the way
um
who's the one which is the one that was
kona's manager
Rick Ross oh there's two of them the
um
the Conan manager was living in this
community and my manager said hey he's
having a party tonight
I know I'm like I'm not going yeah I'm
not going don't ask me to go I don't
want to see that dude I'm here to golf
and hang out I'm not here to to see him
or men defends because I I feel like
that guy was was
purposeful and
eliminating my show
but an ally prior to which is completely
an ally because well also
listen man I mean I spoke to Conan on
the phone
and told him that TBS was a good place
to work and I got [ __ ]
of course talked to him and he says
really talk to him on the phone come
over man it's a great place to let you
do your thing that again the point I I
really think you were that's why I think
if you're gonna go out with a bang if
you're gonna go out and just say hey
let's acknowledge this moment in time I
think the the best
I'm not saying this to just I'm not
saying this to be an [ __ ] I'm not a
fan is to be like I don't know I'm not
saying this to be here I could just shut
my mouth and go hey I I would have left
an hour ago I I really I really believe
this you did [ __ ] you did [ __ ] in the
late night scheme like people are not
acknowledging it you do you did things
outside the box where you did things on
the [ __ ] lot you did things where you
Incorporated people you did things where
you Incorporated fans were like hey
let's make it a party tonight let's
really do this [ __ ] let's blow it the
[ __ ] out you did that [ __ ] I I remember
it I I still acknowledge it and I think
that you really were one of the last you
were the last I honestly there wasn't a
structure to it yeah the last late night
talk show
to have ever existed I I swear to God
want to say that because you you brought
out the last semblance of a party right
uh amongst people so people were trying
to bring it back so people I I hope so
so people would people would would wait
a couple hours before long ass lines and
I would drive by my car I'm like what
the [ __ ] is that they do oh that's for
the show
uh
Lenny Kravitz was a guest and the fro
and we always had big dogs
incredible [ __ ] women I could still
leave
buenos
hey so
in the commercial he leans over to me
goes
is all the women this beautiful every
night I said
I said Lenny you see that those girls
right there tomorrow there'll be
somebody sitting there finer than them I
mean it really was uh
I tell you about the salmon story so
there was this girl over there and she's
wearing like that that was pink or Sam I
said to my property I said hey there's a
girl over there and salmon bring her
backstage
I go where I go don't look you know
right there over here he goes all right
all right Chief I got it go back there
because she's in there boss I go in
there it's a heavy set girl she's got
like 12 [ __ ] racks of lamb uh you
know [ __ ] lamb bones on her yeah
and I walk out like hey how's it going
she goes if you wanted to meet me hang
on a second that's pink [ __ ] he
goes That's salmon
she was not pan seared it's like
I got a call that uh at 12 15 one night
when the show I was [ __ ] home at 8
30. and it was and it goes I'm sorry to
call you I'm sorry to call you Mr Lopez
hi you I'm a I'm the guard at 29 Warner
Bros yeah hey man what's up I'm the
night guard
you know I just I just needed a point of
reference I said what's going on we'll
snoopers guys are still in here like
everybody's gone but they're still in
there and they're playing music and
they're smoking and I don't know what to
do I said hey man just walk away they'll
leave this I said just just walk away
man I'll take I'll take the
responsibility like just leave them in
there don't say [ __ ] to them and just
just [ __ ] bad he was the only one
left in the stage other than just let's
just back away and [ __ ] leave them Oh
you mean a guy guys are having fun
[ __ ] smoke the [ __ ] out man or join
them they'll [ __ ] invite you in
that's awesome you [ __ ] dip [ __ ] yeah
it was awesome and that's the stage you
did West Wing that was [ __ ] awesome
man I'll tell you this if I [ __ ] ever
do another Late Show you're gonna be my
[ __ ] executive producer I swear to
God I'm your [ __ ] god dude in a
heartbeat I swear nobody better than you
nobody better than you let me be your
Guillermo all right let's go to Peacock
and do it let's go to Pizza let's
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] yeah by the way I
I've I've had nothing but respect
because I in
um since Mike coming to LA
but let me ask you a question yes sir
who where when was the first time you
went on stage where and how did you get
to New York
two thousand or no why are you watching
with friends like what were you watching
in your friends comedians not friends
but but somebody you had to say I'm
gonna I'm gonna write some [ __ ] I'm
gonna go so no no I I literally came out
of college came out of college
moved to New York said to my mom and dad
my my father's uh Lincoln Park I go hey
can I crash out with you he goes yeah
stay on my couch I go okay great would
have been the band Lincoln Park no
Lincoln Park over here getting no
Lincoln Square
he goes hey crash with me experience in
New York I go two years I'm out he goes
okay
I started 86 straight I walked down
Lincoln or down Broadway every [ __ ]
restaurant and then I go to uh 50th
Broadway and uh I go hey I'm looking for
a job this guy Brian goes what do you
want to do I go I'll do anything he goes
well fill this out you got a job I go
okay Caroline's comedy club never been
to a comedy club never been to a comedy
show never never like appreciate it just
grew up watching I love Eddie Murphy I
love what about the stairs when you walk
in you have to go down the stairs oh
[ __ ] how great is that the best the best
right they close to him
by the way I'll tell you this right
listen man you go into Caroline's comedy
club and there's like three tiers of
[ __ ] stairs you have to walk down and
it's almost like as a comedian or as a
guest
there's somebody going to the show
you're excited if you're if you're
you're excited if you're a member of the
audience
and you're excited if you're [ __ ] a
performer because that's [ __ ] right
and then I go away you go that way I do
this [ __ ] five months and uh I two years
later
I'm at dangerfields and I pulled a
comedian aside I said hey I uh I never
seen Caroline's rock as hard as you as
you did it you [ __ ] rocked it up I
worked there I was he's like oh okay he
didn't give a [ __ ] but I'm just saying
just saying to you to me as a comedian
now I'm two years in I'm not a comedian
I don't give a [ __ ] Angel Salazar
I said angel
you crushed it I never heard it louder
and by the way I'll tell you this right
now Angel cells are Caroline never heard
it and then I go to um check it out
check it out he had the Boombox and then
I go to [ __ ] Montreal right and
people [ __ ] on me for this [ __ ] on me
for this I don't give a [ __ ] I don't I
stand by this do you give a [ __ ] I give
a [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] but I give
a [ __ ]
I go hey the loudest I've ever heard it
at the just for last festivals which we
both know Montreal Comedy Festival the
biggest country Festival of all of me
I'm still alive I'm in the basement I'm
parting Jimmy uh like all these great
comedians like we're all just hanging
out rocking out [ __ ] having a [ __ ]
blast [ __ ] Jameson all this [ __ ] I go
what the [ __ ] going on upstairs loud
thumping something and then I hear it I
go what I I think a fire alarm's going
off I think somebody I think some
something bads happen upstairs
I ran upstairs
and then I see people laughing and it
was uh Gabriel Iglesias to this day the
hardest I've ever heard people laughing
anytime at one show was Gabriel Iglesias
I've told him multiple times every time
we drink it's amazing I go [ __ ] right
I was in a basement and I heard you I
[ __ ] heard you man that was that uh
one of those surreal moments like as a
comedian where you go oh uh something
bad's happened and then you go up and
it's not that it's it's it's a surreal
experience right okay and that was him
beautiful yeah in
the late 80s I flew Southwest to all my
gigs yep to Dallas to [ __ ] stopped
four times [ __ ] on the way over
and
I was looking at the Southwest magazine
and I saw this this golf course in
Ireland
and it looked like the it looked like
the golf course was was hanging off the
Earth
and I've been playing golf but at public
courses and I wasn't a member of uh
a country club or anything
[ __ ] right
it's in Ireland
it's called Old Head we gotta do this we
gotta do it together look I tore the I
tore the page out of the magazine and I
kept the mat that kept the [ __ ] uh
paper in my wallet like you know like a
condom I [ __ ] pulled it up
and Lee Trevino has already been playing
you know so I want to join that club I
went there three years ago
and the guy was so nice
it says I said hey what do you have to
do to be a member oh you know you come
over here and
get a couple of uh
you know recommendations of golfers of
Trevor Newman who's a sportscaster won
the Masters in 2008 and I put Trevino so
Trevino we met you know we've known each
other for 20 years and Trevino calls
with me goes hey man
I got this call from this guy in Ireland
man I don't say to him Mary was asking
me about you and everything and and you
want I guess you want to join Ireland
doesn't make any sense
so here's another poor guy growing up
and I said hey Leah I found this course
toward the you know I said we tear by
the way this one I put my mic here and I
go I'm gonna listen and I tore the the
page out and leave the book like you
tear the [ __ ] one page out you know
yeah of a restaurant a [ __ ] steak and
church and and he he you know would
usually would be you know critical
nothing you know and then I said I need
a place to go man like I love it over
there he goes I love it over there and I
said
you know
[ __ ] starting to play I never thought
I'd feel so comfortable over there as I
do in Scotland and Ireland
and he's like
you son of a [ __ ] you you can't even
get in this club in Los Angeles you're
gonna go to Ireland I said exactly like
over there they they [ __ ] want me to
[ __ ] join over there and with that
you get
the exclusivity of playing there as much
as you want
they [ __ ] will help you anywhere you
want I got the letter from the guy it's
it's almost like
nobody's written me a letter that
welcomed me that open ever to anything
man
and I'm gonna join that [ __ ] place
and as soon as my shit's over my my
year's over I'm gonna go over there for
a month and play golf unlimited and they
you can they'll make tea times I'm gonna
[ __ ] be over there
that's Humanity I think I I think like
uh so we obviously got you in I'm going
well I think we're two I'm not I'm not
incomplete but you know what but you
know what man
I mean I mean I never thought those guys
but also when I tore that paper out of
that Magazine on Southwest
it was it was beyond my imagination
nobody ever told you you could take the
whole [ __ ] magazine for free
I thought I tore a [ __ ] paid later
some people neglect the fact that George
came up in a time where uh man it's not
it's not as accepted today as it was
back in the day so man listen George I
mean you take it from here but I want to
ask you uh from a comic to Comic like I
respect you I love you I've always
appreciated it but but what is the what
was one of the most arduous situation
you found yourself in
um well I think I think
I think that you we put up our own
obstacles like you know when Freddie
Prince When Chico and the Man came out
in the early 70s I was like wow man this
is a guy light-skinned Latino guy by the
way charismatic and [ __ ] gorgeous
[ __ ] gorgeous and and anointed by the
industry back in the day when the
industry was not anointing right so they
were not doing that Lucille Ball went to
his funeral man
and he had problems in New York like I
think he was bipolar
and you try to commit suicide in New
York
and I don't know man like you know a lot
too so I mean nobody gets that hot I
mean sure yeah [ __ ] man I you know I
actually saw a thing where
he does The Tonight Show in 73
two years later he's hosting the Tonight
Show but then he was on one time with
Johnny and he wasn't that funny by the
way by the way his set was [ __ ] great
and his guest hosting he was [ __ ]
great so I I know yeah but yes yeah yeah
so it's all and Sammy Davis Jr was on
the first night he was on and Sammy
Davis Jr was you know how he would
always laugh real big and just crushing
it so you nail it
but also
I think you know we had the same manager
and he said he was a boy in a man's body
like he was six two and very attractive
and people thought he had the answers he
looked like a man but he's really a boy
inside he's like me so my apologies so
before we embark on this next moment in
in in time I'm just gonna say this you
were
I I again my apologies but I I love you
okay I love you and I think you're one
of the few that were part of a cloth
that came into that can acknowledge uh
comedy from here forward to go uh this
is what it was this is what it is now so
I I just I'm just kissing the ring for a
second to say hey man you [ __ ] did it
like you really
I just appreciate you when I say when I
uh sold out uh
I think it was like 22 shows in a row at
the amphitheater the writer of The Daily
News which used to get delivered to my
house
wrote about me that I still paid homage
to my heroes when I surpassed those guys
and I was like I didn't feel like I'd
surpassed um
uh those guys at all you know like to me
I mean he took the
oh he took the numbers and stuff like
but I just couldn't
acknowledge that I that I was anywhere
in the neighborhood of those guys also
when I used to go to the Laker games
when my show was on and they would show
they show all the stars and they would
show Jack and they would show me and it
would be a huge Applause and the guy uh
Bill Plasky from the only time says I
want to do a uh a story on how you're
the new Jack Nicholson I was like [ __ ]
that I said we're not I said
[ __ ] I said we're not doing that
[ __ ] I said
not at all [ __ ] you I said [ __ ] you
we're not we're not I'm not touching
Jack yeah
they're losing right now
so
um
but George
come on dude that is
that see people don't realize Like
Richard
that picture means so much more to
comedians I think than
like you are I mean but but George
you're that you're you're Richard to me
like you could think that right but
boom boom boom it's it's three degrees
of separations one degree and so we all
go oh Bobby Lee Bobby Lee's crazy right
but Bobby Lee is the conduit to that
generation Bobby Lee
is the conduit to you
oh dude come on the first show I did was
with I did it man Bobby Lee that is the
[ __ ] by the way DL is
um not to negate anybody but deal to me
is uh-huh
not only somebody who personifies like
show business because I saw my at an
airport three times in LAX I never
walked up to him I could never walk up
to him because it was like I feel less
than because when I saw him
he was dressed like I was for the show
and I was like dude it's 6 a.m it's 6
a.m at the [ __ ] airport why are you
dressed like this he dressed like the
show was happening in that moment
DL to me
is one of my top fives a hundred percent
of all times I I [ __ ] love them
let me go officially in record and
saying I love you yes DL was good he was
good to me I met him through George he's
just a good man he watched me and it it
he's a great man and he really is I mean
[ __ ] fantastic he's another I think I
think um aside from his comedian I think
these guys he's just a great person hey
you know I think these guys
like you man I think
they're [ __ ] big-hearted guys man
like it has to start somewhere yes it
has to start somewhere that's not on
paper man like you know I listen I I
have a lot of I have a lot of
limitations like I think you know like I
only really try to perform where it it's
in my strength you know there'll be a
guy that [ __ ] Ron Pearson that does
audience warm up this [ __ ] 30
years and he'll go out there man and I
would last [ __ ] five minutes man sure
yeah it's just like
everybody can settle into if you look at
get up and watch a lot of War stuff like
everybody would dig it's almost like
these guys are trying to dig trenches
where they can survive some
[ __ ] dig deeper than other guys
like I would notice that right that's
your point George
um at the uh I'm at a hotel next to the
comic store
and um
and the manager next to the store knows
him he goes I'll get you a room I go
okay give room I look up
I wake up today and I look up and I see
George Lopez and my daughter yes on
Lopez right and I see that I go that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] crazy he's [ __ ] right
and I go that's [ __ ] great how
[ __ ] that's the dream that's it right
there and so I'm sitting there and I'm
sitting there having a
you know cup of water
Flapjacks and it comes up every four
minutes I go how [ __ ] great is that
that is the [ __ ] [ __ ] right it's like
you did it you did it in this moment of
time in this moment of time you did it
because there's moments in time of for
everybody for
the entertainment industry there's
Babylon which just [ __ ] bombed but
Babylon was singing in the rain before
Singing in the Rain and people don't
realize that Hollywood is ever evolving
and I want you to remember in here
[ __ ] you did it we did it we're
doing it we're doing it right now on a
podcast I want you to put your number in
there because you and I
are gonna do things together [ __ ] yeah
buddy a hundred percent but I um no
because without a right without one end
two don't get in
and I'm I'm telling you man the first
trip around the Sun I would say with my
first show was
was a [ __ ] fluke
you know it was a fluke no it wasn't no
your first trip around no
I'll say this right now it was not a
flip because for Sandra Bullock to to
invest all her uh all of her she she had
moments and and and now in retrospect we
both know okay we both know because
Vince Vaughn bet on me Sandra Bullock
bet on you so we have moments where we
can say okay in retrospect we can say
this but in reality we know this
Sandra Bullock's bet on you is bigger
than mine
she
took all of her equity and put it on you
right and then you [ __ ] came in you
came through not not only that so much
so it's resonant today that it's on a
[ __ ] billboard where I'm in a [ __ ]
hotel and I go [ __ ] right that's a
guy that's a stand-up that is only not
only somebody I appreciate but also
somebody that is still resident maybe 15
years after his first break yeah and
somebody took the chance on him and now
you're going to take the chance on XYZ
or whatever but that isn't a [ __ ]
therapist nothing is listen my I agree
with you press up this [ __ ] oh
well you were at the pilot listen up
listen but also but also
you know
um
you know Mayan you know uh mine you know
and was funny and mine's been funny
forever and then you know we get
divorced and there's the whole mother
father thing
and my therapist says look at it this
way mine chose to be in your profession
right he didn't choose to be a producer
sure or someone behind the scenes so all
of a sudden now you have your kid in
there it's not it's not it's not Masiela
Lucio that's right that's right
Constance it's it's somebody that's your
[ __ ] blood
so any hit to her is a hit and I'm gonna
tell you man I saw her
uh three nights ago she came over
and I look at her as a woman as a
comedian as someone who's paid her dues
and also somebody who has a television
show but they don't give you shows like
she was the key to Lopez versus Lopez
not me her gen Z life her issues with me
became the show and I became the guy
that came through that like if they
weren't digging mine there's no Lopez
versus Lopez
and they were digging mine they were
like we we love mine mine smart or
answer this [ __ ] nepo all this [ __ ]
you know baby [ __ ] I'm gonna tell you
something right now baby [ __ ] where's
the [ __ ] Camp [ __ ] you
it by the way it's twice as hard it's
twice as hard for Tony Rock for your
daughter anybody to go oh it just it's a
layup it's not a [ __ ] lamp it is
twice as hard for that individual to to
come up and go I'm gonna do this I
sought firsthand with Tony Rock Tony
worked three times as hard to establish
a name upon himself it infuriates me so
I think people these days everybody is
looking for any shoes to go well I'm
going to create create an excuse it's
like no create a a validation for you to
uh have some semblance for Success don't
don't negate the fact that you're
creating an example to fail it's so
[ __ ] business it works Tony Rock is
fantastic you never hear of Daryl
Chappelle
all right listen man I could we could
talk to you
listen man I've never I've never [ __ ]
met anybody that might have watched as
much [ __ ] more comedy than I have
well you [ __ ] are totally
I mean I I've I've been through it I saw
Sam I saw dice I've been with I've been
with all of landisburg [ __ ] uh uh
dick Vaughn I've been all I [ __ ] John
Fox I've been with all of them I've seen
them all through night from 1979 and
when I sit with you here I feel like
you're you know when the Buddhists go
over there go touch the things
I feel like it's touch it's spinning
that thing dude I'm the real man and I
don't and you don't get that [ __ ] from
anybody [ __ ] right love you boys
where's the where's the proper camera
is it this one no this one that one this
one
I'm gonna tell you something real quick
for those that go down the annals a
[ __ ] late night I promise you this I
promise you this do the [ __ ] research
do the [ __ ] research and I guarantee
you George Lopez is the [ __ ] king of
late night let me see that I sat with
Prince I love you buddy I'm not joking
I just want to know who's going down the
anals
two fingers three hangers
hey I said you have a heart attack on
the field